ناري في ذلك الوقت
[تصفيق]
المدرب التاريخي للشياطين الحمر وصانع
فرحه جماهير الالترافل
[تصفيق]
كل ده بيرفع الالقاب في المملكه المتحده
واعتاد اعتلاء منصات التتويج
سون
[موسيقى]
اسكتلنديه عام
1941 بدا رحلته مع كره القدم لاعبا في
مركز المهاجم عام
1964 وتنقل بين عده انديه بين الرينجرز
ونال الكثير من الالقاب ابرزها هداف
الدوري الاسكتلندي برصيد 31 هدفا
مسيرته التدريبيه انطلقت في سن الاثنين
والثلاثين مع انديه الدرجه الثانيه عام
1974 فقاد نادي سانت ميري الى دوري
الاضواء وحقق لقبه في ثلاث مناسبات
متتاليه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مو مشكله
نادي مانشستر يونايتد عام
1986 بعد فتره لم يحصل فيها على اي لقب
طوال 19 عاما انتاج سياسه انشائيه قوي
للفريق على المدى الطويل تعتمد على تنميه
المواهب الشابه وشرائها والاستثمار فيها
المانشستر يونايتد استثمر في لاعبي مصر
رينجز وبكام وسكولز وجاري نفيل الذين
شكلوا جوهر يونايتد القوي في اواخر
التسعينيات وبدايه الالفيه الجديده
وجدد دماء الفريق بعدها بسنوات بجذب مواهب
صاعده ابرزهم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
ووين روني
وغيرهما حصل عشرات الالقاب المحليه
والاوروبيه منها 13 لقبا في الدوري
الانجليزي ولقبان في دوري الابطال
المده التي قضاها في الاداره الفنيه
النادي انفق اموالا اقل من الانديه
المنافسه مثل تشيلسي وليفربول وحقق ارباحا
من اللاعبين الذين باعهم اكثر من معظم
منافسين منحته ملكه انجلترا
الرفيع في المملكه المتحده اعتزل التدريب
عام 2013 بعد 26 عاما في قياده الشياطين
الحمر و 39 لقبا في جميع البطولات المحليه
والقريه
وفراغ لم يملا حتى الان
حاولت فيما سيوفيرسكو
[تصفيق]